Let me share with you a story I read in
a book and I read this years ago.
It was the name of a missionary named
Judas. I think you somebody confirmed it
right that is a name.
Judas
can you guys from India tell me because
I remember reading the name was Jessas.
Oh okay. Thank you man. Now so it's
Juas.
Thank you. Okay. Yesas. See, and then I
was right. Let me tell you this true
story. I read it in a book. I wish I can
find that book. I am not lying. I try to
be as honest as I can and I try to
recall things. Remember, I'm getting
old. Okay. I read this in his book. He's
a missionary. You want to hear this
story? Okay. Okay. Yeah. So, yes. Good.
So, servant, you are you ready for the
story? I've shared it in the past and
this is going to lead to my miracle
story because of his influence. Okay. He
influenced me to pray this prayer and
I'm starting to pray it again.
In this book that he that I don't know
if he wrote or was written about him. I
don't remember but I remember the book.
I even remember what the color was. He
went to a particular tribe that had
these witch doctors.
These men who
had the entire village under their
control because they could do miraculous
feats by the power of demons. These
witch doctors would actually do
miracles. They would actually curse
people, put hexes on people that would
actually work because they were in
actual contact with demons. They would
see these demons. Now, they didn't think
they were demons, okay? They would be in
contact with them, see them, and hear
them. And these demons empower them to
do signs and wonders to put the
villagers in fear. So are you listening?
So he comes and preaches the gospel of
Jesus Christ. And people are getting
saved. So the witch doctors warn him.
Listen to this. The witch doctors warn
him. They say, "If you don't stop what
you're doing, we're going to invoke
curses on you and our gods are going to
punish you." He goes, "Do what you want.
I'm a servant of the Lord Jesus Christ
and he will protect me. So now two weeks
went by
all of a sudden two weeks went by about
two weeks approximately if my memory
doesn't fail me. And the witch doctors
all came following before him. You know
what they said to him? Do you know what
they said to him? I read it and I'm
going to tell you how it applies to me.
A miracle story with me. Not lying about
my part. And I have no reason to deny
this part. This man's miracle. The witch
doctors fell and they go, "We want to
serve your God, Jesus Christ." And he
was shocked. He goes, "Because our gods
are not greater than him. He's greater
than our gods and we want to serve him."
He's astonished. Just a couple weeks
ago, they're threatening to put hexes on
him so that the demons would kill him.
And he wondered why.
No, I wish I did, Emanuel Lewis. I'll
try to find it. Pray I find it so I can
show it to you. He wondered why. You
know, you know why? You guys want to
hear this now? Get ready to be blown
away. They said, "When we invoke our
gods, which are demons, spirits, to
attack you," they came back to us and
said, "Listen to this. We can't get near
his home because there are angels
with swords surrounding his home."
Okay, that's what the demons told them.
We can't get near his house cuz they're
angels surrounding his home with swords.
Okay, that's one. So then they said, "We
invoked more powerful gods, more
powerful demons." Now, they don't think
they're demons, more powerful spirits
than these ones. Those more powerful
spirits, now watch this part. I'm going
to show you where the Bible says, "Some
demons are more powerful than others.
Not all demons are equal." Just like in
the kingdom, you have a hierarchy of
angels. Some angels are more powerful
than others. Like Michael is more
powerful than others. And in the
kingdom, believers will have higher
ranks than others. Some of us will be
higher in ranks than other than others.
In the demonic realm, in the demonic
realm, some demons are more powerful,
more wicked, more cruel, more vile than
others. And I'll show you from the words
of the Lord Jesus Christ in a minute. So
then they invoke their so-called more
powerful gods. The those gods came back.
You know what they said? They're they're
in contact with these witch doctors
because they're they're human channel.
They go, "We cannot get near the home
because not only are there angels with
swords, there is a wall of fire
surrounding his home. A wall of fire
surrounding his home. This man cannot be
touched." And when these witch doctors
heard it, they knew Jesus is almighty
over the gods of the nations. And they
gave their life to Jesus Christ. Okay?
Do you hear what I just said?
Now, let me show you how it connects to
my miracle story. And I know this is
true because I read it with my own eyes.
Okay? Can I now connect this wall of
fire, this wall of fire with my story?
Okay. That miraculous story that I knew
was real
influenced me to pray. Now, let me show
you my story. I would then start
praying. I would then start praying.
Exactly. Hebrews 12:29.
Holy Spirit, surround me with a wall of
fire from your presence. I would ask the
father in the name of the Lord Jesus,
even asked Jesus, Lord, surround me with
a wall of fire from the Holy Spirit. Now
guys, no one knew I prayed this prayer.
Nobody. I didn't tell anybody. This was
my own prayer. Again, the Lord bears
witness. I will answer to the Lord if
I'm lying. I used to work for South
Asian Friendship Center, who was an
outreach to Hindus and Muslims. What we
would do is we'd bring in teams of
Christians and we would train them and I
would be assigned the role of teaching
them how to refute Muslim objections
because Christian teams would come and
we would take them to the mosque or we
take them to the Hindu temple to see
what it's like and then we would prep
them and prepare them to do ministry
outreach urban city outreach right urban
ministry. Now, one particular group as
I'm debriefing them and refuting the
objections of the Muslims, they got up
to put hands on me and pray for me. Now,
when they finish praying, they leave me
a card. I can't find that card. That was
like over 10 years ago. I'm talking
about early 2000. South Asian Friendship
Center. Now, folks, listen to what I
just said, so you don't know I'm lying.
So, you know I'm speaking the truth. I
never told people I would ask God
surround me with a wall of fire from
your Holy Spirit like you did Judas. You
surrounded him. Surround me Lord please.
All right. Nobody knows I pray that
prayer. I opened the card and these
brother sisters are leaving comments.
One sister that remembers the sister.
You know what she said? You guys get
ready. You want to get blown away?
Guys, I'm trying to blow you away how
real God is. And he shows himself real
if we believe. And he shows himself real
if we cling. And even if we fail and
fall in sin, he is faithful if we
acknowledge our sin and ask the Lord for
mercy and healing. He loves you. He
doesn't delight in punishing you. He'll
heal you. Now, I read the comment and
the sister says this to me. Look what
she says.
I just want you to know, look what she
said. how
the Holy Spirit protects you. How God
protects you. As we were praying, this
is her. As we were laying hands and
praying, I saw a wall of fire
surrounding you. Okay,
my hands right here. So, I'm getting I
saw a wall of fire surrounding you. And
as we laid hands, the wall of fire came
forward and surrounded us.
I want you to know that's how God
protects you. This sister had no idea
that was my prayer. But she saw in the
spirit realm the wall of fire
surrounding me as confirmation from the
Holy Spirit. Sam, you
Sam, your prayer is heard and this is
how I'm protecting you.
Okay. How did she know that? Brethren, I
am not lying. Lord will hold me
accountable. I never told anyone. That's
how I pray day in day out. Day out. How
did she know? That's my prayer. She
didn't know. And you know what's
amazing? She left and never got the
chance to hear how she confirmed the
miracle. Till this day, I don't know who
the sister is. I forgot what she looks
like. She does not know that her
statement confirmed that God answered my
prayer. So she doesn't even know she's
part of a miracle. She doesn't know. Now
maybe she's watching. She's going to
hear it. So what motivated me to pray
for a wall of fire to surround me and
now my daughters? Jess's testimony. When
the demon saw
angels and a wall of fire surrounding
him, I said, "Lord, in your love for me
in spite of my failures, would you
protect me with that wall of fire from
your glorious, beautiful Holy Spirit?"
And in the card, she says, "I want to I
want you to know how God protects you."
When we were praying,
I saw a wall of fire surrounding you.
And as we laid hands, it came forward
and surrounded us. How did she know
that, man? Now guys, you atheist and
agnostic who don't believe in God and
the spirit realm, explain to me how she
could see that unbeknownst to her.
That's what I was praying day in and day
out for months.
Erns, you know what Jesus says to you?
Thomas, you have seen me and yet
believe. Blessed are those who do not
see and yet believe.
You're more blessed when you don't need
a miracle to confirm your love for Jesus
Christ, but you remain faithful
nonetheless. Now, is that clear? Do you
guys understand?
I am a witness to that miracle. I'm not
a witness to Jess's miracle. And now you
heard a miraculous story. Now, the
beautiful thing about the Jesus Film
Project, guys, if you don't believe
these miracle stories, contact them.
Say, "I want to go on a mission trip and
I want to meet these people. These
people that are seeing these miracles,
they're alive today." and they told you
they're in Nigeria. It's not 100 years
ago where you can't verify it. It's like
when Paul said in 1 Corinthians 15:6,
more than 500 brothers seen Jesus alive
physically, bodily after his death. And
most of them are still alive at the time
of my writing. So there are about 500
living witnesses when Paul wrote go ask
them if they saw Jesus as alive and the
tomb is empty and he now reigns in
heaven in his glorified physical body
and ask them will they ever recant or
are they willing to die for that claim.
So likewise today these miracles are now
you can b ver verify them now these
people are alive now in Nigeria in India
they will tell you we see miracles and
because of that we worship Jesus Christ
they're alive right now folks don't
believe me contact Jesus film project
look I'm a skeptic I'll pay my own way
I'll come with you to these villages I
want to see
I want to see
so You skeptics, God is a miracle
working God and he's still doing
miracles today whether you like it or
not, leaving you no excuse for your
unbelief.